[Music]
I've been
messing around
with
Uchinoshima.
[Music]
23 I was looking forward to living with Yae,
so I'm sure you'll be very happy.
Ah
, Papa Dag, the case of accepting Edo fur was resolved peacefully through this discussion.
]
n
I was afraid of forcing you me
[music]
me
ana
[music]
tan
UKara
Isuzu Giga c to Kirishima Come on
It was resolved with
Tokai, where
did you say
that
?  Oh, oh
[music]
Lorne Kirishima
I've decided on spring when I'm
going to squeeze my fingers Oh, you're angry
Kumiba I know what you
're doing Your usual behavior is the best
Especially when you can't see the color of remorse, it's the best
No  Oh, thank you very much It's
ironic, you idiot
[Music]
But your ability is real The group was put together
at noon
I wonder if the gorillas who are polite to work are set Come in
[Music] To my
daughter's house  Kada,
Ayaeka-chan, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, you've
grown so big,
don't you think?
I'm going to be the caretaker of Uh haha ​​school Caretaker
Is it my responsibility that I'm not enough for the royal castle's too free Temee?
[sound  [Music]
Thank you so
much for taking care of this little girl
from now on
Shio
[Music]
This guy is anti-Chinese, but he got a difficult job
.
No, the
boss's daughter's caregiver
That Kirishima-san,
how many boss's daughters are the fixed prices
?
Iihara
: I'm sorry I can't say
it.  I can't do it
ah ah ah
Uhira I'm not a mother with beautiful skin
I'm not strict I'm not going to accept a girl who's struggling alone
Don't pull me out on the 8th side, I'll give you the next
[music] It's the
same dance, right?
[
MUSIC] It's not like
that.  I'm worried I'm
from Jean Seian I work with
electricity
Hmm, if you use the old one, you might be able to do
it.
Korondashiya Tokoro d tsu
Kirishima's friends are hiding in the back I'm too
embarrassed to show
up, so I
'll
choose them.
Gyaaaaaaaaaaaaa
me  It's my fire It's a
seizure month
Eh, after
all, there's no one here Ah, it's not
right
No, if I say I'm embarrassed, why don't
I add it?
I'm not even an insect
Ou I forgot my school bag Absolutely
Yes, that's all for now
Everyone has mistakes
Yai-chan good morning
Now I'm major from school
[music]
Today I brought a souvenir for Yae-chan
Eat when you get home  Hey,
I'm going to take a break from the store today, so I
'm going to school for the time being
.
I-chan,
you weren't feeling well Something happened- I don't think anything in particular happened
Hey, don't you always feel like that for young ladies?
I was yelled at for not entering the room
. Did Yae-chan really see the mettle of the king?
Oops, my hand slipped
.  I really like
Yae-chan, so I thought she would be happy, but
I really wonder what happened
dea
Kirishima-mura,
where are you going?
I don't think you forgot to put it out that you hid it this afternoon, but I don't think you want
me to come.  I couldn't take a break from work, but
I didn't say it out
loud, but I remember feeling like I was
getting rusty.  I understand the reason,
but why did you want to hide it so much in the registration
?  Music]
But the family can't come.
tan
Wow,
if I say it, it's going to be troublesome, but yes, I'll
cheer you up Joto when you're back.
Let's do it, it's a
big deal ana
Let's all do our best in class even in front of our fathers and mothers
Ah,
do
n't worry, I may not be able to grant many of your wishes,
but you don't have to erase those wishes
[Music]
You don't have to be patient
Parents and guardians, please take
a look
.
]
Is it a cherry tree?
[Music]
Yes, the skin on Kumigami's back
[music]
God 7
1 Yai-chan's father
Mn, you're a heavy drinker
My dad is cooler, so there's a reason why it's the
best There's no difference, but it's different
Please excuse me, then
[music]
B:
Of course,
what are you doing?
I'm a little worried about whether or not I
'll be happy.It was the same with Kirishima on the day of the visit.I
wondered if my daughter would be happy
if I went, and what if things didn't go well.
I
think that Kirishima has been good to a certain extent, so I'll be
sure to convey my feelings of Ojo to the boss
Kirishima City
I'm going to give it
to my
father.
Because I like it,
I wrote it because I wanted my father to see
it.
has
just become a caregiver and may still be a new person
But
[music] It
's like I learned about Yae-chan's favorite food
from now on.
To
be able to become a family of chan
Isn't that a bit too hurdle
[music]
What do you want to do?
]
Yeah
[music]
rane
ah ah ah
eh
ha
tan
me
[music]
Let's go on a super road
and point at the convenience store
The shadows of Funatsu lined up on the other floor What should I buy today?
Thank
you
[music]
Dadadon It's like a hot cake After all, that face is voxy far
yeah yeah
What kind of Kirishima-kun can I meet
[music]